So what's the take home message from today?
Take home message from today is not just that it's happening right here in,
in your own backyard and that we only scratched the surface.
Um,
and when I say that we only scratched the surface,
we didn't talk about a work that's going on and making fuels from algae that and
talk about things that are using Titus Hannah and Shell fish shells to,
to purify water and on and on and on.
There's so many groups right here in our own backyard.
But then all of this was done using the 12 principles of green chemistry,
the 12 principles of green engineering and some matter of design,
uh,
that a number of these are being,
um,
uh,
are being patented.
A number of these are already being spun out into and to companies.
Um,
that it comes back to something that we've said throughout the course of the,
uh,
the course of the semester.
Um,
and that is that tomorrow is going to largely be what we design it to be today.
Looks like it does today because we've designed it to be this way,
either consciously or unconsciously,
that,
uh,
the,
the basic framework of our society and our economy,
the products,
the processes look like they do today because we designed them to be this way.
We set up design criteria that made it look like this.
And hopefully one of the take home messages from this semester is that the
status quo needs to be displaced,
that the status quo is unsustainable,
that the status quo is largely,
I'm going very quickly off a cliff,
whether it's we're talking about energy or materials or the wide range of things
that we,
uh,
we discussed even today,
that it needs to be displaced and reinvented.
So one of the things that this semester hopefully has given all of you is the
tools to be a part of the displacement of that status quo should you choose to
do so.
Um,
and I emphasize to be a part of that because I'm fully aware that this class is
diverse set of backgrounds and even more importantly,
a diverse set of futures.
What's really important is that the future needs people in very different roles
to make,
to make it happen.
So maybe you're a chemist or an engineer inventing these new products and
processes,
or maybe you're the person who's making the policies,
whether it's government policy or policy that is going to enable and empower
these changes.
Or maybe you're the person that's running the,
the the not for profit group that's,
that's demanding and pressuring and shining a light on the status quo that needs
to be displaced.
Or maybe the person in finance that's going to,
um,
provide the investment and venture capital and private equity he needed to make
that maybe the person in the,
in the patents a law that actually understands how to provide incentives for,
uh,
allowing change to happen rather than empowering the,
the,
the current embedded technology.
I don't have any idea what your future's going to entail and probably needed to
you,
no matter how much you think you do,
it's going to take a whole lot of twists and turns.
But hopefully now you have a toolbox that enables you to,
uh,
if you so choose,
dismantle the current status quo and to a more sustainable one.